[Music]
so good afternoon has to know so I gotta
give a quick introduction on the topic
the API I think everybody literally if I
would ask for hands I would be surprised
if I don't see anybody has used an API I
I'm a hundred percent certain you have
it's that you big quiz these days but it
it's kind of assassin on in them for a
rest api these days although pretty much
everything that is interface' belitz can
of an api if you think about it even if
you go to your bank clerk you're
interfacing with them you reach out your
credit card form right it's essentially
an interface it's not very it automated
it's not an application programmable
interface but it is an interface so if
you think around the world or you think
the world in the sense of these
interfaces you see how how much
interfacing day is going on every day
now we want to go into these interfaces
that we work with more so we're going to
talk about rest we're going to talk
about other forms of AP is we're going
to talk about things that are happening
inside companies and outside companies
because let's face it wherever
integration needs to happen is typically
add these borders and before we go deep
into this topic I want to have Tyson at
him and introduce themselves really
quick in a few sentences so maybe you
can do that if you get a few sentences
so yes my name's Tyson heck would I work
for for Braintree i started Braintree in
Asia as first employee I actually had
left a company called paypal and joined
a start-up out of Chicago and then was
acquired by that company
ended back in inside paypal so my paypal
korea is six and a half years in total
and it been here for about two and a
half in singapore and still a very
technical person though in one way or
the other night comes to the top yeah
exactly sort of technical here technical
enough a month yeah I a workers pay
paralyzer full stacks off for engineers
and I'm a free software enthusiast I've
been doing a lot of open source from two
thousand eight or so and things like
that I've been part of open source
projects like yo men are web pack and
things like that so that keeps me
running off work and let's meet me so
far alright so how did I come up with
this topic well it turns out I was
actually working for Standard Chartered
as I mentioned for the last three months
and there's a push here in singapore
from the monetary authority that every
financial institution of a certain size
has to open up AP ice and i think that's
a pretty interesting move that have not
never thought about that like suddenly
we have to deal with government
regulations on interfaces we create or
something i don't it's not that bad yet
but like it's just one step away from
that and I'm like wow this is crazy like
how does that happen and for those that
are not from here the Singapore
government has a scheme or push called
smart nation that is going on over the
next year's where they want to automate
and enhance integrate ability with big
companies customs postage services
financial institutions you name it to
increase the efficiency of the labor
essentially because the bank clerk that
takes your forms what are they doing who
are we kidding they're just taking a
form typing it into computer right if
you take that part out you might
actually end up with less mistakes in
the data it's the human factor so this
is what made me think about it and I was
trying to help them about okay how do we
set up an API and what is required to do
an API and here we have people that
essentially work in businesses who do
nothing else but being a really good API
so maybe you want to drag us to the
beginnings of braintree because I think
it was very much set out to be exactly
that
payment platform as a service and like
how you thought about creating a product
that is an API well I think you know
braintree had a life as developer for
developers for a particular reason it
started with you know there were no
sales people in the organization at the
start and worked for many many years
because developers have driven the
requirements of the product and or
service not just in payments in general
but Braintree has it its core is a
requirement to both me meet the needs or
meet the needs for payments but probably
more importantly Braintree started with
an idea which was it shouldn't be so
hard right so anyone that's integrated
payments here knows that it's not being
it's not always pleasurable or fun or
interesting most of times it's difficult
because it's usually from businesses
that have been around a very long time
and may not have the services that
plug-in easily it's usually a push
rather than pull concept in payments
Braintree set out to do it differently
not just from even a code base but also
from a commercial base so again anyone
that had the joy of starting a start-up
knows it's not easy to either even get a
bank account get your business
registered I mean it's a lot easier
today but let's think back seven eight
years ago surprising it doesn't seem
that long but it was and is you know has
difficulty so Braintree like a lack of a
number of other of the emerging
companies in the infant act said which
shouldn't be so hard so at the core what
we believe and I guess this is what
others should build for is make your
product easy make it accessible make it
like it that something that ships is
essentially user experience right that's
what you think about if you create a UI
on the web or for mobile it's like you
think about Oh easy fast you know like
don't overload me make it a wizard like
so is there such a thing like developer
experience and that sends it was all
developer late I mean it you know each
person that came into the business was
you know not from a
they didn't have experience in you know
fintech services what the hadn't
experiences were building for other
products and finding it hard to
integrate a FinTech I mean look banks do
a great job at many different pillars
when it comes to integration when it
comes to innovation it hasn't been great
for a number of years in many respects
and we often say if they'll really good
their job companies like Braintree
shouldn't exist companies like PayPal
shouldn't exist because they should have
got it right a long time ago the
advantage now as we work closely with
banks and other financial institutions
because again it's it's now that that
middleware or being invisible in making
sure commerce works so our hope premise
are all promises just to make commerce
work use this because we're quick and
easy and we take the pain out of
payments and make sure it works but
actually get on to the function which is
the most important to you which is your
business you know you shouldn't you
shouldn't need to be and ever spend that
much time on being payment experts so
yeah and their topic came Anthea you are
in a proper developer in that sense
working for paypal and when you
integrate with api's on all times what's
maybe the most painful experience you
had with API so you don't need to name
who it was it was just what about it is
the most annoying piece so that you if
you build api's ever can maybe avoid
these things yeah the most painful part
like there are many painful parts like
probably have to talk about the most
painful part rather I think this is just
very much common I not not any
particular company as such but most of
the people who use API sand integrate
them face this issue one of the major
ones being up the document is out of
sync say say you have a schema based on
which you are trying to build your UI so
you're kind of not wait assumes it use
case where the back end isn't ready it
with their services but you just have
the schema with you and your being your
friend and assuming that mocking a
response that the back and would give
but sometime down the line the schema
got changed and once the back and
integrates the API whatever response you
get is out of sync that's one of the
major pain factors all right so quality
of documentation against interface
obviously I guess
it's for most of us kind of a pain point
if it's out of date and not maintained
very well which which leads right into
the developer program almost right
because if you don't have an intentional
effort supporting these interfaces that
you're building documenting them well
keeping it up-to-date which needs to go
hand in hand with the development of the
AP is how do you think about a developer
program that's more for outside facing
API is rather than inside facing api's
with a new corporation right what makes
a good developer program then maybe you
have examples outside of PayPal
braintree yeah i would like to quote an
interesting node module called swagger
here I assume two of them are using it
already that the advantage of that being
is it or Auto generates the documents
for you as as a menu update or schema
you have the document which is
reflecting your current schema something
like that would really be advantageous
the other pain factor would be a
debugging stuff say if I could cut an
example of Sailor there was a case where
there was a missing transaction from
from a merchant right so the merchant
has done a transaction but he doesn't
see it in the list of transactions so
how do you how do you go about debugging
it like at what layer this i read it
really occur was it was it the API
failed to fetch the data from the DB or
the UI fetched a failed to fetch the API
or did the UI misinterpret the API or
did did the the API misinterpret the
data which is which it fetched from the
DB so there are a lot of combinations
and scenarios that can happen there so
debugging sums and some scenarios which
you can't reproduce easily becomes very
painful at times yeah so people at the
time I remember had XCOM like funny
story in 2007 I was a certified paypal
engineer my got to go to all these tests
and you know fill out forms and answer
questions about how the hippie I said
paypal work they did this at the sight
of their their big conferences in the US
and you could sign up for it I go
through a bunch of courses and then you
go to certification there's really funny
nobody does that anymore right like an
open-source API interface certificate
and like you know now how to do
integrate with an open-source API on
or build one and Express or something
but companies did this at the time and
then there was a whole range of SDKs
which eventually moved the interface
from being on the web like a web service
to like being inside of your coat right
so that you can integrate with the
library instead of an API now you can't
really say API without what is the most
modern trend in all most modern maybe
depends on where you are and how to
design any more ambitious application
which would be the micro service
architecture I think ten years ago they
called it so ax and a service-oriented
architecture it actually have something
on that line I don't know if you
remember this can we go to the slides
really quick anybody remember that one
it was the gravestone of the misled so I
engineer so you know there was this joke
that happened in an interview like I
asked the candidate up do you use soap
and he was like he was pretty end of
episode is like yeah I use it every day
so like these are all the buzz words I
believe we had soap and then we had
things like then the rest thing happened
and then we had the full stack thing
happening then we'll be like server less
the cloud I feel it's all the buzz words
but it's still the the old game with a
new phase it's just a face and it will
just face off with some other new
buzzword but if you if you consider
future of api's it would be more AP ice
and probably a pas for AP ice so is that
all going to be HTTP rest like I don't
know you're like Braintree offers a
bunch of AP ice is that always if you
rest or what kind of API is are there
what's even a bigger question me that's
for sure but the nice part it's on the
website you see so I mean to the point
thing but let me know that you bring up
more that it's not even just about today
we we spend probably more time on making
sure that we're available for all the
modern platforms and emerging platforms
we also know that there's a lot of
legacy out there as well so we actually
look to the communities to build those
linkages as well because it's only so
far you can go and
the other aspect and I think importantly
is there is only so far you can build
with the financial service products
especially in payments because if you go
too far into someone else's backyard and
there's a problem you know we're talking
about real money here so you know we can
actually have a detrimental impact so I
think there's also you know if you're
looking at the requirement of of any
sort of service just always appreciate
that you can only go so far before you
know they might go into the wrong side
of the the house to play with so we're
really conscious that we provide the
best version across whatever platform
you're playing with so that you can draw
down and create a transaction and and
monitor and or you know protect yourself
from fraud and or capture card details I
mean look you know if you're not doing
tokenization in your product you should
have been for two or three years yeah so
to me you know we have plenty of
resource it comes down to making sure
you integrate it right and it's like it
needs to be purpose-built right and then
that sounds so I think a good indicator
like I've I know few companies these
days specifically in Southeast Asia and
maybe no to that build api's as a
product like the the so-called platform
as a service or integration as a service
like that hasn't that typically thing we
consume or use from companies that came
up in Europe of the US but like here I
have not seen like startups which is one
of the industry's that you can't really
disconnect from Singapore these days I
haven't seen many come up with the
product like that specifically targeted
to enterprises for integrate ability it
exists for sure but not not as much so
purpose-built very important part there
and I think a good indicator that its
purpose build should be the fact that
it's already a service you offer and
people are liking it and they just would
like to use it more efficiently like you
know credit card applications things
like that if banks move into the
direction to make these things
automations and Singapore is even
talking about
having a unified ID I think it's called
my info that financial institutions can
get access to which i think in other
countries would raise every privacy flag
on the planet here in Singapore it's
like okay yeah we have all the citizen
data why don't we make that available
for institutions to use so that they
don't need to ask you to fill out your
form you just need to confirm that you
would like to share your data with them
and they can get your data set in the
most current form from a government
institution it's a interesting way to
think about it and then well yeah I'm
sure for those who shop online you've
actually probably shared more data with
the online store than you will your bank
or government yet you feel people feel
worried about where the data is and into
certain point people should but I think
the responsibility of anyone that's
building a service needs to be to make
sure the data is protected have service
providers that can protect the data in
the best fashion they can tokenization
is a great first step especially if you
have that secure that's not on site I
think most people know that that's
pretty much the yeah that's a gone idea
you know there's no point storing
anyone's data centrally or in your own
servers anymore you know everything
needs to be tokenized but to your point
around you know building for purpose and
for AP eyes and seeing the growth of AP
is my thing would be that if you are if
you are doing that this is two aspects
to a really good a p.i usually number
one is it's been built for a purpose but
number two if you build it for your
biggest customers or your biggest the
biggest service provider you're working
with there's a high chance that your
other customers are going to require the
same requirements or a subset of those
will so if you look at braintree a lot
of the product and service you see is
because one of the customers we've
worked with or many of the customers we
work with have had that requirement so
we build out a lot based on those
requirements so the advantage is that
you get to share in a lot of resource
and development done by other large
organizations and I think that's what
you've got to look at yourselves for
anything your building or using make
sure it's building built by people that
are you being used for the next
generation not the previous make sure
they built it in
using it that the who else who ever else
is using it also likes it and has helped
develop it in some format now you're
never going to know we're never going to
say our this was built by X or Y or you
know this is why this feature set is
with ours yeah but you can pretty much
assume it's been built for someone who
we've worked with for for a while
because they see a need and generally
the need is customer LED and they want
their customer to have a better
experience do you have some something
that you when you did you create ap ice
in your life like yourself that we're
exposed like things that developers
definitely should take care of when
creating an API I always start with with
one of mine which is check whatever is
your input data first before you do
anything else and if it's even qualified
to do anything for you and have proper
errors but maybe yeah so add on so i
would probably open the token ization
probably have a single sign-on zorro
tokens and things like that and the
other one now everyone tend to do is
have have a rate limit on your api's if
you're opening it to the public so that
it's not really misused and sometimes it
gets tricky right so you are trying to
block them probably on an IP or they
could be switching on dynamic IPS or
probably using some combination of their
location that predict and probably even
mocks or you can mock mock up everything
so it sometimes get tricky to handle
rate limits on how many requests App
Engine [ __ ] on your open API is the
other one that the other paradigm some
of the companies are following or like
like Google for example is like on in
white api's I don't know how good go to
go to design is that like you get a user
API is only on in white there might be a
designer there might be a reason behind
there might be a business that might be
a business decision as well but that's
that's a new paradigm that's opening up
on interesting now on the last thing
looking forward this talk is about 2017
so what's coming up maybe some of you
have read this I saw that like they're
certain website that have gone to web
sockets for serving advertisements yeah
yeah so that it can't be blocked by your
ad blocker anymore because it's a socket
connection to their default data
connection and it's just that all the
advertisements
fet through the web socket so you know
like it's one way of integrating and
surrounding things like now I he read
that firebase is actually has gone back
to XMPP because they thought web sockets
was too heavy for what they were doing
to have the fast like API that they need
to be a real-time database that's
cloud-based right where do you see this
going yeah uh so as I was studying it
well it's all the buzzwords and history
will kind of repeat itself in a new and
a different fashion like XMPP being one
of the examples or in the front in word
you should say that don't mix up your
JavaScript and CSS and keep them all sup
right and these days it's like inland
everything doesn't matter the browser is
smart enough to figure out what goes
where right so it's like the history is
repeating itself but in a different
fashion and more powerful sense but in
terms of API is like I speak I feel
building with purpose of course it's the
major priority but building smarter
api's is the new thing like if he could
code few companies like apathy or API
dot say i right they are building
smarter aps that could recognize a
natural language some natural language
processing and return an API internship
say for example you could just say set
my room temperature to 30 degrees and it
will respond with JSON saying that but
this is the current temperature and this
is what I'm setting it to and this is
the device ID something like that that's
building with purpose and smarter api's
is a new way and the way the aps going
at I feel so I'd like to hear from you
exact with your hands again on who is
currently working on like exposing some
kind of API express API Ruby API I don't
really care but something that like
somebody outside of your department or
company needs to integrate with that
would be really interesting for me to
see so yeah very little actually so
maybe interesting so the rest is mostly
consumer because I assume like everybody
else has at some point used an API Oh
interface to work with because it's like
the common theme developer programs who
those that were developing ap is
actually have thought about the
ecosystem were surrounding this API how
people will interact with it like to go
back to the point of developer
experience which was part of my
engagement like how do you work with
developers on that sense so are you
thinking about developer programs or is
it literally just an integrated API
maybe for those that raise the hand on
those can I can I see a few hands on
those that think of it more holistically
that down to three enterprise companies
great speaking of Microsoft arm and
Standard Chartered great select to add
on Thomas especially in paypal right
like we have this concept of inner
sourcing so in a sourcing as I says like
how the open so free and open source
model works we're trying to integrate
the same model within the company so
since it for example a be a be on work
across teams and the communication
across the teams would be very much
similar to what happens in a open source
project like like github we internally
use get up as well the enterprise get up
so we could just go at create an issue
ask for them or say like hey your schema
is there but your aps reckoning this how
do we fix it or how we go about creating
a new attribute in the indira question
that's interesting something we talked
about before it I guess one of the most
common things to use api's for use you
have a front end and then you have a
back end so like show of hands again
just to get a bit more feedback from you
guys on who creates fully static front
ends that just talked to the to a
back-end service two three four five six
and okay like for me for the last few
years i think it's the way to go forward
in the sense that you disconnect these
two quite well but then we ran into this
discussion earlier where you have
feature requests coming from the top and
they want to have it in the front end
right and then suddenly the back end
doesn't have the functionality so it
needs to trickle down into it right and
I thought like you guys have a really
interesting approach to to work with
this environment maybe you can yeah so
it's talking about the inner sourcing a
paradigm but I still feel one thing that
that lack
or I don't know how all of you guys are
doing is when we call ourselves a
full-stack team or what I feel is like n
to n maybe querying the database
generating the API consuming at creating
the UI so the end-to-end process should
be done by the single team so the
advantage of this would be is like you
you're not waiting for the other team or
you're you're not running on assumptions
that the API would respond in a certain
manner or or the schema would be so and
so so that that would be a nice
experiment to do but it's it's it's
really a hard thing to do when it comes
to an enterprising there there's some
legacy code that's running then there's
there's a lot of untouched score like in
probably fear of touching of breaking or
slow-moving things and but they're on
the contrast there is a lot of migration
that's happening from legacy stack to
the new stack like like in our case it's
more of C++ and Java to node right so
thanks to bring it back to open source
actually with this conference is in
parts about right like great tools in
open source that to help you creating
better interfaces these days like like
swagger being one of the very good
exists and being one of those any
contributions or things that that
Braintree is doing on that line oh look
i think the look what we've always I
said it's very large to develop a base I
mean still eighty eighty percent of the
people that work for our business right
on the developer side we're so we're
very developer laid the I think just
using any tool available because I'm
guessing those teams in here that a
could be quite small so you don't have
the joy of having a large team you can
bring together you may be your only team
or you might be one of two therefore you
are the both it back of house front of
house all her house whatever is i think
is about working together and trying to
ship things that are that you know ship
products which make sense so if you're
on enterprise side what are the real
requirements versus the nice to haves
you know I think you know we've got to
prioritize you know it's probably our
biggest challenge is we have no shortage
of requirements we what we have a
shortages of time and a shortage of
people potentially or the amount of time
that you want to change your code and or
talk you know make make changes in
general so make sure that any changes
are worthwhile make sure that when
you're shipping them that they have a
direct impact to the customer consumer
or whoever your the end user is just
because they seem to be a nice to have
for a person or organization it's always
worth checking you know what was it for
I think in anything to do with
architecture you know from our end and
because I drive from a business
requirements you know often it's when
you ask the question of questions you'll
understand what the real requirement is
and again there is no point reinventing
the wheel often the answers or the
product you've got is already exists
you've used in somewhere else try and
make it repurpose it to make it fit for
purpose sometimes you have to build it
new but if you're going to build it new
go back into your business or go to the
businesses you're talking to and see how
many other people could have the same
requirement I think this is the
advantage of being larger and for the
larger organizations you have this you
have this because you have multiple
customers multiple stakeholders you have
the advantage that you know have it you
need to have a voice you need to say
we're making changes and this what
making them for who else has this
requirement because you can build your
business case really fast or I'll tell
you can you know kill that product or
project and focus on something that's
far more important you only have a
couple of shots a year or whatever your
cycle is to make it work make sure it
really works Thomas like sorry to break
but this just reminded me like six six
or seven months back in the node word
specifically there was this oting done
on different clients on or either node
modules that would help you to build
restful interfaces and based on a lot of
parameters I I record it right it was
rest if I there's a module called rest
if I that kind of one in terms of all
the different parameters that was
considered the oat so so along its wagon
maybe rest if I is one of our very good
candidates these days so I want to leave
you with one last message as well I
think ap is an open source you should do
api's in open source properly as well
it's like the fact that other people can
see your code should not prevent you
from also creating great interfaces into
your coat
and ideally I don't have to look in your
code at all if I want to use something
that you're creating maintaining or
contributing to and like the interface
is still well documented well laid out
and works well right that's one thing
that I've come over and open source
quite quite often is that it's like yeah
I just go in and like work around
specifically JavaScript kind of invites
you to do it because if you can look
into any package you can go around like
change prototypes and all this kind of
stuff I think the fact that developers
can do this makes those libraries that
actually do a really good job and
creating interfaces stand out even more
so just to that the one thing I would
say that I would challenge everyone to
do and if you get the opportunity and
you're playing with some sort of our
code if you see so were you playing with
anything to do with the API so if you
see something you'd like let us know hi
seriously the best feedback we get is
from you and I think sometimes you hear
I why didn't you have this and why don't
you have that that's really actually a
good question don't don't ever not think
to put the feedback in and I think large
organizations that are represented here
all feel the same way we don't want to
have a back office or your people in a
room pushing out this is what our
product is that's the old way of doing
things in new ways tell us what you
think so we can only go as fast as you
tell us all the things you need yeah and
it's quite easy to relate whenever you
build an interface you know the guy on
the other side is also going to be a
developer so all the pains that you
received in the past from integrating
with anything is something you shouldn't
want to put on the people on the other
side that you're building for when
creating an interface they are also
developers and they also like their time
insanity so please build great api's and
please contribute more to open source
with that i want to thank tyson and
haven't for being you on the panel as
well goes up to them outside round of
applause if you like this
[Applause]
you